day five at the place in Essex I've
established the Shepherd to be kept on a
very short leash and his food is beyond
tragic so for the first time in four
years Israel shut the place down
hello Michael this is John Conte and
just returning your call
with no customers we can throw
everything at revitalizing the image and
most importantly a god-awful menu whose
fault is it really it's mine and nobody
else now it's a fresh start let's get it
back on the road and very soon we'll be
on the motorway when a restaurant
drastically changes his food it's
important to back it up with the right
hemisphere a couple of coats of paint is
an easy way to dazzle your customers and
give you a second chance today is just
about getting the whole place back to
look sharp and crisp clean an item walk
even say wow I like it
the kitchen's been scrubbed clean and
the ovens fixed at last but that's not
all
fulfill it seems all these new ales have
come at once I'm shaking I'm actually
going to have a kitchen with proper
equipment Israel antara must be bleeding
somewhere this one's going home with me
I'm sleeping with it tonight not Dave
from now on plastic sauces and frozen
foods are barred the new menu will be
cooked strictly from fresh ingredients
and I first buy is a four kilo ham
drizzle
the honey and the brown sugar over it's
a delicious steal at a cost of just ten
pound and with a little lateral thinking
it's a potential money spinner this ham
how far has it gone already fried eggs
with ham croque monsieur peen hammer
soup can you see just how much money you
can generate from one ham yes surrounded
by all this fresh food there's a
tangible change of energy in Philips to
young chefs the seasoning is quite even
so I noticed right so it's not too much
while Munya tends to the soup al Simoes
carefully preparing a pot of delicious
bubbling squeak what do you think
leaving more salt yeah good I'm glad you
said that
mmm fresh food mmm [ __ ] ham they're
crazed in your [ __ ] hands yeah you're
supposed to be guiding them through this
you know that yeah how many big chefs
did you work for when you were their age
quite a few yeah and did they kick your
ass oh yes yeah do you hate them for it
I love them you love them for it do you
think they love you when you show them
nothing I think now I'm gonna learn
you've made that we start to finish
before he takes a job to do take a
[ __ ] photograph fill it that's your
reference yes at last it feels like
we're getting somewhere
the chefs are infused and the dining
room has been transformed almost beyond
recognition but as it stands the outside
of the building is selling all our hard
work short buildings beautiful you know
so show it off but we've got to get rid
of all the tacky [ __ ] stuck to the front
of it now that you mention it and you
see from a different point of view we go
with promoting drinks we've saying
cocktail knife is a knife and we go menu
display denier tatty yeah there yeah is
what you're waking up to it and I'm glad
you're starting to open your [ __ ]
eyes because it really is important you
know the [ __ ] word the place well you
know that's got to go and you've been I
think it's big consensus we going for
Saracens cafe bar yeah [ __ ] perfect